your skeleton skeletal roam around so
that's also Phoenix a that's the stuff
that if you and Sookie date that's the
stuff if you put on a lava it
regenerates know this is this is so
great you have to decide like what type
of the stuff I want and what I think we
got some more so calera whatever it is
she ate I don't know I don't know bro
need like six furnaces your skeleton
please clear my auto switch if you can't
tell it's switching to the sword don't
worry it doesn't look like it is it is
torn don't get another digit of it or
don't worry um I guess so much or it's
Phoenix I on the ground over there type
over I was gonna say I was like it seems
like I'm gonna rush back stack iron
oh my gosh this is so awesome bro the
gems mod I have I just kidding it even
if you don't want the gems because I
think it makes coal and iron like a lot
more frequently spawning it's so much
cool oh my gosh almost like two and a
half stacks probably have to start
heading out soon yeah probably it sorta
saw a wheat farm even though I want
carrots characters like bread we're
playing ashes two and a half carat
replenishes to butter bread costs three
wheat and a carrot is just a carrot so
character much better or that's been my
experience give me yo stuff
your skeleton we just got all these
intersecting lines okay probably should
I things is the end of it yeah you
surprised you can explore by standard it
so it's chill it's chill chill schools
beans bros all out of it so awesome if I
made it all the way break you and you
and you and you and you and Eero some
health isn't gonna repeat regenerate Oh
all night of torches dang it didn't even
realize that okay I'm going to kill you
oh my gosh why does my armor so good he
shoots me out even taking damage oh yeah
okay we're going to need to escape and
give out how many torches I don't really
want I really want to make more torches
so I'm going to try finding my old all
we're going to get you though and I
can't see and a creeper mate we're going
to attack me all right ah ok we get out
here break you always from 26 crassula
50 iron 21 malachite for citrine 6 Jade
10 signal light and one agate age eight
probably suppose all terribly I don't
care all right we got a letter like I on
the ground so this is the my staircase
my second circus you can see the non
effects of smooth lighting so they
turned it down and we're going to find a
way to get out Oh Frick I heard the bat
swing slab and it sounded like Slyke
like an Enderdragon or something scared
me could get out i'm gonna try getting
out that way dirt
be a bridge I'll pick up this iron too
because why'd you leave Vanar behind and
you should you can turn all the these
oars into blocks and you can also use
them to color sand so yes we've made it
out awesome now where's my house oh
there's my sugar cane farm oh I above my
house I'll kill the chicken there's my
mind all right first thing first two
more you bad boys at least boom boom
boom torch that one you up now I
probably put I want to put everything in
there you can afford it cuz I'm all rich
on coal all rich on these helical get
for furnaces all stack cooling them all
right then I'm going to cook the
malachite and crystallite none of the
other stuff it has enough to a warrant
ok I'm going to make a blocks chest yes
ok
so my good then all my blocks blocks
would be above so gravel I want to keep
that would keep Kabul not this is block
tion so you take all block block block
block block block block block block
block block my boys crack a little bit
there just catch it yeah did you be
honest did you catch my voice cracking
dirt class I can fit it okay block block
block no blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah one eat block now I
didn't put anything in this one I can
put some Phoenix head over Christ okilla
malachite iron yet the textures are a
little bit funky but chill you see if I
have a I take some that glass and I
don't need a craft able to do this but I
do that now what more then what am i
doing I can I can do it with a glass
have to do with sand I need Sanford
though dang this is like so I love this
it makes it so open so we need to pick
up some more this year sand luckily we
have like a ginormous each once i'm
gonna try sound oh my gosh has some loud
out loud sounds how loud is this for you
guys
it's quite loud you kill some cows to
say like I place this hand and place
that nobody i have no idea their month
forget it i stress just forget it you
turn into dies waiver it you know I'm
just um maybe get to cook I'm 9e somehow
you turn into dust one sec bring you
back to how to speed somehow you turn
into dust and yeah I don't know phoenix
at phoenix i look so cool see ya phoenix
aight pickaxe mmm let's make it if i
make it picks a passage citroen looks
freaking cool yeah so it looks seemed
like kreisel killa and malachite pretty
common telling me to make a sword also
the swords have different textures like
citrine sword so go test this on a mob
yoohoo ma beam ave it'll be careful
because i don't die except 24 levels
gotta start a cow farm soon that I need
a wheat that is the reason I mean tweets
I'm on hard
wait does the switch my wow other way
this is a good way to check which one
does it switches which is oh so I think
I mean citrine is better than iron this
will kill in one hit yeah I auto
switches was a switch to the thing does
most damage oh we got pack of scouts
let's go scouts there's gonna be
difficult since all fire aspect oh my
gosh it's not good okay I'm making no
I'm going for the water nope nope once
that goes